les résidents de calvaire n'ont pas eu
droit à leur fête annuelle à nu les
approches du conte à virus mais ils ont
eu droit à une belle course cycliste
ils étaient 80 au départ et dès le coup
d'envoi donné par les chaluts du mot
mais une mineure il est rejoint par
quatre fuyards gérant algeco dean et
clavier mais bien vite le groupe explose
et dumont et alger prennent la tête à
trois tours de l'arrivée le peloton les
reprend dumont remets le couvert il
rejoint par stanislas carnier rizal et
boris carène dans le dernier tour car l
east and that accélère et se retrouve à
deux le sprint est serré et la victoire
finale est pour mickaël stanislas la
troisième place est pour axel carlier
vous servir
[Applaudissements]
et
je les laissais passer pour pouvoir
aspirer vers la fin parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de vent de face donc c'est ce
qui me plaît a été très difficile et ça
fait plaisir aux deux de rivaliser avec
lui je sais est arrivé comme ça en tout
cas ça fait ça fait plaisir
je lance mon sprint je suis un petit peu
plus loin je regarde je me relâche je
sais pas si ils me doivent entre la
ligne mais c'est un très grand champion
et comme on dit que le meilleur gagne
rendez vous est pris les 1er 2 août
prochain pour les championnats de
guadeloupe le contre la montre
individuel toutes catégories qui se
disputeront à petit canal